>> MARSLAND: Hi, my name is Paul Marsland
and I’m here to talk about EZAsset. So,
what is EZAsset, EZAsset is a Web based asset
management system for both government and
business and we also have another side for
home inventories. So, what we do with the
government and business is we track computers,
IT equipment, weapons, medical records for
hospitals. And then on the home side we track,
art, jewelry, cars whatever people have for
their assets. So, what are we integrated with,
with Google? We’re integrated with Google
Docs for importing and exporting asset information
in this system very easily and quickly. And
then we are also integrated with Calendar
for a maintenance Calendar task for the asset.
And then we just ported EZ Home over to the
App engine. The App engine has been pretty
exciting so far because of many different
reasons which we’ll get into a little later.
So, a little bit of history for EZAsset and
it’s deployment. First of all we started
EZAsset in Columbus, Ohio—-we had our own
servers. And so, we’re managing as a hosted
application in our home office. We than decided
to move to the Cloud because we have lots
of expectations and excitement about the Cloud,
and so, we went to EZ Two. And so, in EZ Two
they gave you a very raw, very raw set of
servers and so, you have to control patch
management, low-balancing database management
back-ups, everything there. And so, when we
were on EZ Two for about a year and then App
engine was brought to our attention. So, we
decided to move the App engine for a couple
of different reasons and mostly the reasons
are maintenance and scalability. So, Google
is very, very good at keeping secure and scalable
solutions, and so, why should we waste—-not
waste—-but should we use the resources on
our side to do things that Google that is
very, very good at. We are good at development,
we are not necessarily good at server management
and so, we are letting Google do their thing
while we get to do our thing. Some other things
to add about the Google and EZ Two differences,
so, today we are using EZ Two with a lot of
our integration points for our business and
we’re using All Sub for authentication means
for Google users to be able to use Google
processes such as Docs and Calendars for things
that we didn't have to develop yet are still
able to add a rich interface for any customer.
For App engine, for the reason that we’re
moving a lot—for the reason that we’re
moving over to App engine is because we don’t
want to have to worry about the server, server
integrity, the patching, the security features,
the backing-up. We believe that Google should
be able to--Google is very good at this and
we believe that we should let Google do what
they’re passionate about and we will do
what we are passionate about, the development
of an asset management system. So, moving
to App engine, so there have been some interesting
things with App engine deployment. So, we
have our product over on the EZ Two which
is pretty much like developing on your own
servers. App engine is a little different,
so App engine provides its platform level
which gives you the capability to have this
scalability and high availability of your
application to all your users so you don’t
have to worry about that. But, at the sane
time there is cost, there’s pluses and negatives
to this. Negatives are yet to develop inside
this framework and this platform that it allows
for this capability and scalability. So, what
that means is that you have to do things a
little differently. One of the big challenges
that we had was the database, and so, today
or before we were on the EZ Two, we were using
the Hibernate connection to a POS grass back
end. So, a sequel based data store. Today,
we are now using the JPA to go into the data
store for the Google App engine. Other things
that were challenges were uploading, this
seems kind of silly but with normal servers
that you have, you have no issues with uploading
data to them because you have control over
where people can have access to and dump these
things into wherever you want to do it. For
example, images, so we take images for assets,
so you can take a picture of, say, your car
and say, this is what my car looks like. For
App engine, it’s a little different. So,
we have limitations because we have to actually
place this information to the data store,
so, there is a one mega byte image restrictions.
So, we have to do some resizing of images
as people upload images that are very large.
Also things that were technically difficult
were--there is a file limit size on the App
engine. And so, let’s say a thousand files,
a thousand files which is something that developers
never had to worry about in the past because
you have your own server, it doesn’t matter
how many files that you have. That’s it.